>>> IT'S BEEN
MORE THAN TWO WEEKS SINCE FOUR
IDAHO COLLEGE STUDENTS WERE
MURDERED.
POLICE IN THE COLLEGE TOWN OF
MOSCOW, IDAHO HAVE SAID ALL
ALONG THEY BELIEVE THIS WAS A
TARGETED ATTACK.
NOW THEY'RE CLARIFYING THAT
STATEMENT, CREATING A LITTLE BIT
OF CONFUSION -- A LOT OF
CONFUSION, ACTUALLY, AS STUDENTS
AND RESIDENTS HELD A CANDLE LITE
MEMORIAL SERVICE LAST NIGHT.
AS POLICE WERE TALKING AS THIS
WAS GOING ON ABOUT A
MISCOMMUNICATION THEY HAD WITH
THE COUNTY PROSECUTOR'S OFFICE.
VERONICA MIRACLE IS LIVE NEAR
MOSCOW.
THIS HAS BEEN THE QUESTION
PLAGUING THIS.
WHICH IS WHAT POLICE ARE SAYING,
WHAT THEY AREN'T SAYING AND WHAT
WE STILL DO NOT KNOW ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED HERE.
>> Reporter: THAT'S RIGHT,
KAITLAN.
A LOT OF THIS CONFUSION IN THE
LAST 12 HOURS SEEMS TO BE AROUND
THE NOTION THAT TWO OR ONE OF
THE SPECIFIC ROOMMATES WERE
SPECIFICALLY TARGETED.
I'M GOING TO READ PART OF THEIR
STATEMENT THEY RELEASED LAST
NIGHT.
DETECTIVES DO NOT CURRENTLY KNOW
IF THE RESIDENTS OR OCCUPANTS
WERE SPECIFICALLY TARGETED BUT
CONTINUE TO INVESTIGATE.
POLICE HAVEN'T ANSWERED OUR
QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS CONFUSION,
THE GOING BACK AND FORTH.
I THINK HERE IN THE COMMUNITY
ALL THAT MATTERS IS THAT A
SUSPECT STILL HASN'T BEEN
ARRESTED.
THE UNSOLVED FATAL STABBING
DEATHS OF FOUR UNIVERSITY OF
IDAHO STUDENTS LEAVES THE MOSCOW
COMMUNITY WITH GRAVE UNCERTAINTY
AND LITTLE INFORMATION MORE THAN
TWO WEEKS AFTER THE ATTACK.
>> YOU'RE JUST GOING TO HAVE TO
LOVE EACH OTHER, HUG EACH OTHER.
>> THE UNIVERSITY HELD A VIGIL
WEDNESDAY WHERE THE FAMILIES
SPOKE ABOUT THEIR LOSS.
>> SHE WAS SUCH A HAPPY -- JUST
SUCH A GREAT KID, A PERFECT
LITTLE BABY.
AND SO JUST SMART AND FUNNY AND
BEAUTIFUL.
>> THAT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT
MESSAGE THAT WE HAVE FOR YOU AND
YOUR FAMILIES, IS TO MAKE SURE
YOU SPEND AS MUCH TIME AS
POSSIBLE WITH THOSE PEOPLE
BECAUSE TIME IS PRECIOUS AND
IT'S SOMETHING YOU CAN'T GET
BACK.
>> VICTIMS KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND
AND MADISON WERE CHILDHOOD
FRIENDS.
>> SIXTH GRADE THEY FOUND EACH
OTHER, AND EVERY DAY THEY DID
HOMEWORK TOGETHER, CAME TO OUR
HOUSE TOGETHER, THEY SHARED
EVERYTHING.
AND IN THE END THEY DIED
TOGETHER.
IN THE SAME ROOM AND THE SAME
BED.
IT'S A SHAME, IT AND HURTS WITH
THE BEAUTY OF THE TWO ALWAYS
BEING TOGETHER SOMETHING THAT
WILL -- IT COMFORTS US, IT LOET
US KNOW THEY WERE WITH THEIR
BEST FRIENDS.
>> A SPOKESPERSON FOR THE MOSCOW
POLICE DEPARTMENT SAID THEY WERE
STARTING TO RECEIVE TEST RESULTS
RELATED TO THE INVESTIGATION.
IT COMES AS POLICE ARE
CLARIFYING STATEMENTS THAT SAID
THE MURDERS WERE TARGETED AND
I
ISOLATED.
THE LATEST STATEMENTS SAY THEY
DO NOT KNOW IF THE VICTIMS WERE
TARGETED AS SEVERAL COMMENTS
HAVE CITED THIS INCIDENT AS A
TARGETED ATTACK.
INVESTORS RETRACED THE VICTIMS'
WHEREABOUTS ON THE NIGHT OF THE
MURDER BUT STILL HAVE NOT NAMED
A SUSPECT.
ON TUESDAY AUTHORITIES REMOVED
CARS FROM THE CRIME SCENE.
THE IDAHO STATE POLICE HAS
PROVIDED SECURITY FOR THE CAMPUS
AND THE COMMUNITY GIVEN THE
MOUNTING FEARS A MURDERER IS
STILL AT LARGE.
>> I THOUGHT IT WOULD MAKE ME
FEEL SAFER BUT IT DOESN'T
BECAUSE IT REMINDS ME THERE'S
STILL SOMEONE OUT THERE.
>> Reporter: CERTAINLY HERE IN
THE COMMUNITY EVERYWHERE YOU GO
THERE IS AN INCREASED SECURITY
PRESENCE.
IDAHO STATE POLICE EVERYWHERE
TRYING TO MAKE THE COMMUNITY
FEEL SAFE.
KAITLAN.
>> YOU CAN SEE WHY THEY DON'T.
THANK YOU FOR THAT REPORT.
>>> I WANT TO BRING IN CHIEF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND INTELLIGENCE
ANALYST MR. JOHN MILLER.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
>> GOOD MORNING, DON.
>> THIS STORY IS FASCINATING IN
THE SENSE IT'S A SMALL TOWN,
RIGHT, AND THEY DON'T HAVE
ANYONE YET -- INITIALLY THEY
SAID THEY DIDN'T THINK IT WAS A
THREAT TO THE PUBLIC AND NOW
THEY'RE SAYING IT POSSIBLY IS A
THREAT TO THE PUBLIC.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> I THINK THEY'RE GETTING TIED
UP IN SEMANTICS WHICH IS A
SYMPTOM OF NOT HAVING A BREAK IN
THE CASE THEY CAN TALK ABOUT
THAT'S NEWSWORTHY.
SO PEOPLE ARE GOING BACK, TRYING
TO INTERPRET STATEMENTS WORD BY
WORD.
I THINK WHAT YOU HAVE HERE IS
YOU'RE GOING INTO THE THIRD WEEK
OF THE CASE THAT MEANS THERE'S
BEEN ENOUGH TIME FOR DNA RESULTS
AND OTHER THINGS TO COME BACK.
WHAT THEY'RE LOOKING FOR THERE
IS WHO ARE THE KNOWN
CONTRIBUTORS, THE VICTIMS AND
PEOPLE WHO LIVED IN THE HOUSE,
WHERE IS THAT UNKNOWN
CONTRIBUTOR?
THEY TAKE THE UNKNOWN DNA, PUT
IT IN THE KSYSTEM WITH THE FBI.
THAT GIVES THEM TWO THINGS, ONE
EVERYONE ARRESTED WITH A
FELONY'S DNA.
SO THAT'S A GOOD START.
BUT SECOND IT GIVES THE DNA IN
THE SYSTEM RECOVERED AT OTHER
CRIME SCENES THAT ISN'T
IDENTIFIED.
IT DOESN'T LEAD THEM TO A
PERSON, IT CAN LEAD TO ANOTHER
CRIME SCENE.
SO ALL THOSE WHEELS ARE TURNING
NOW, AND THOSE CLUES ARE GOING
TO BE COMING IN AND RUN DOWN.
>> THEY HAVEN'T SAID ANYTHING
ABOUT A SUSPECT, DOES THAT MEAN
THEY DON'T KNOW ANYTHING OR
THEY'RE NOT READY TO SAY IT YET.
>> YESTERDAY THEY SAID WE HAVE
NOT NAMED A SUSPECT.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THERE HASN'T
BEEN A SUSPECT.
THEY'VE BEEN THROUGH A HANDFUL
OF SUSPECTS THAT HAVE RISEN AND
FALLEN AS ALIBIS HAVE CHECKED
OUT, AND THEY'LL GO THROUGH
MORE.
>> ARE THE KIDS SAFE?
>> SO --
>> ALL THOSE COLLEGE STUDENTS.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT YES, BUT NO.
THERE'S AN INCREASED POLICE
PRESENCE, THE STATE POLICE IS
PATROLLING THE CAMPUS AND TOWN,
ALONG WITH LOCAL AUTHORITIES.
BUT UNTIL WE KNOW THE WHO AND
THE WHAT AND THE WHY, IT'S HARD
TO SAY THIS TARGETED DISCUSSION.
TARGETED OR NOT TARGETED, HAS
SOME MEANING.
WHOEVER WENT TO THAT HOUSE CAME
THERE DELIBERATELY.
IT APPEARS WITH THE INTENT TO
KILL EVERYONE INSIDE.
ARMED WITH A PARTICULAR WEAPON
THEY BROUGHT FOR THAT PARTICULAR
PURPOSE.
WERE THEY TARGETING THE HOUSE,
AN INDIVIDUAL INSIDE, OR WAS IT
ALWAYS JUST GOING TO BE
EVERYBODY?
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE STRUGGLING
IN THE WHY DEPARTMENT.
SO THE MORE RANDOM THIS IS.
IF IT'S A DRIFTER THAT SAID I'M
GOING IN THAT HOUSE TO KILL
EVERYBODY, THE LESS THEY'RE
SAFE.
IF IT'S SOMETHING TO DO WITH ONE
OR MORE OF THOSE PEOPLE IT'S
CONTAINED.
BUT UNTIL THEY KNOW OR TELL US
THAT ANSWER, IT'S HARD TO TELL
EVERYBODY, EVERYTHING IS SAFE.
>> AND WE'RE LEFT TO WONDER.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH, JOHN
MILLER, APPRECIATE IT.